Okay.
So the last time that we met,
we talked about the idea of logos
operating on chaos in order to to bring
being into being.
And that's predicated on a worldview
that
it's not precisely materialistic and its
fundamental orientation.
So it's predicated on a view point that
one way of looking at being is that it's
a,
a place of potential,
maybe have unlimited potential.
And what acts on that potential too to
bring it into being is what modern
people would call consciousness.
But what the ancients called logos,
which I actually think is a better word
than consciousness.
I think it's a more encompassing word
because it doesn't only involve the act
of being there so to speak like the
existentialists would say,
but it also involves active exploration,
both both physical and imagine stick as
well as communication about the results
of that exploration.
And I think that it's perfectly
reasonable to face the world as if what
you're facing is a pool of potential
that you are capable of shaping.
And then the question is into what do
you wish to shape it?
And I think that's actually the ultimate
question.
You know,
people often ask questions like what is
the meaning of life?
And I actually think to some degree that
that's an ill posed question.
I think that you can observe the many
meanings of life.
Some of them are negative,
no one questions their reality.
And some of them are positive and we're
more likely to question the reality of
the positive meetings that manifest
themselves.
Because we get overwhelmed with our
apprehension of the fact that life is
tragic and that we're finite in mortal.
But that doesn't mean that those
meanings aren't real.
Okay.
I would also say that
as I've considered more and more
carefully the way that value structures
might be hierarchically organized and on
farther and farther out to what I think
of as the edge or the ultimate reaches
of that hierarchical organization that
you know,
your,
your identity as a finite individual
being sort of localized in time and
space.
Now in here,
that that encapsulates generally what
people think about themselves as,
as,
as real individuals,
but that there are metaphysical spaces
outside of that that are,
they're hyper real in some sense.
And in one of those metaphysical spaces,
you're the embodiment of nature and
culture in in the most real of senses
and in an in a metaphysical space that's
just beyond that.
Yeah.
You're the logos that transforms order
into chaos and sometimes the reverse and
then outside of that,
which I think is in some sense the final
metaphysical domain.
The question is what is it exactly is it
that you're up to?
And I think that what you should be up
to is the attempt to transform being
into something resembling classical
conceptualizations of paradise.
And that has nothing to do with the
attempt to impose an ideological
structure on the world so that you can
bring it into alignment with your a
priori convictions.
That's not the right answer.
The right answer is something different.
I mean,
one of the things you want to ask
yourself is,
you know,
is it better to work for the abolition
of misery or for its extension?
We try to think in some senses the
fundamental metaphysical question.
I think that was posed properly in the
20th century because we learned at that
point exactly how far we could push.
Okay,
voluntary evil without bringing
everything to a halt.
And I think we pushed it right to the
limit and you know,
maybe we're still not done with that
game.
It's hard to say,
but things look like they have improved.
I would say overall since 1989 since the
Berlin wall fell down,
although you certainly see signs of
recidivism frequently and you see that
right now,
for example,
in the,
in Russia now the Russians are trying to
find their own way and there are afraid
in many ways of western individuality.
They believe that it's got a fatally
nihilistic element and that one of that,
that one of the consequences of that
nihilistic element will be the undoing
of everything that culture has produced.
It's of any value.
And so the main Russian political
philosopher at this point who's one of
potents advisers is a,
he's a nationalist of sorts.
But
yeah,
the reason I'm telling you that is
because the ideological conflict that
began in the 20th century is by no means
over.
And it isn't obvious that liberal
individualism constitutes the final
solution to the problems of mankind.
No,
that's not,
I'm not saying that.
I'm not saying that as a cynic because
yeah,
as far as systems go,
it's a pretty damn good system.
But I think that people in the west
still suffer from a spiritual sickness.
That's not,
that's a consequence of what needs she
outlined and Dostoyevsky outlined as the
major philosophical moves of the 19th
century.
And that was the demolition of
metaphysical belief by rationalism and
empiricism,
some of which was fully justified and
some of which I think was an
overextension of the emergent forms of
knowledge.
Yeah.
So I'm going to go through the rest of
Genesis today and explain to you what I
think it means and then I'm going to
tell you why I think that's relevant.
And so this is an extension of the
stories that we've been talking about
during the entirety of the course.
Um,
we talked last time about the fact that,
okay,
in the second genesis story,
God takes eve out of Adam and what that
might mean.
And the idea there is that it's
something like the feminine or material
world has to be transposed into
something that's symbolically masculine.
In order for it to become
properly oriented.
So the idea in some sense is that human
beings,
not just women,
but human beings in general,
have to rise above their material
substrate and transform themselves at a
psychological level or at the level of
consciousness.
And that that's actually a real level.
And if you accept,
accept the presupposition that
consciousness is actually an active
agent in the extraction of order from
chaos or in the extraction of reality
from potential,
there's no reason to,
to delegate consciousness to a empathy,
phenomenal to,
to the,
to the status of something that's
empathy.
Nominal,
even though it seems to depend on the
existence of a material substrate for
its manifestation now requires a
different way of thinking.
Okay.
So we're going to start with the idea of
the garden and the Lord.
God took the man and put him in the
garden of Eden to dress it and to keep
it.
Now,
what appears to me to be happening in
this story is the f now this is multiple
stories that have been edited together
over a very long period of time.
And so people had evolved in some sense
their own traditions of,
of accounting for the structure of
reality.
And then when people came together in
their tribal groups to make
civilizations that were larger,
it was necessary for the people who were
working at an intellectual level in
those cultures or at the level of
storytelling to try to determine what to
do with these old stories so that the
core truths could be retained.
And the apparent paradox is ironed out.
And that happened continually as the
Bible was written.
It's,
it's an ongoing process.
It certainly is not something that
stopped yet.
And so it's an attempt in some sense,
to bring the story of mankind together
into one place and to make it
comprehensible,
to turn it into a comprehensible literal
narrative.
Um,
the idea that that's associated.
Like if you look at the standard Marxist
and psychoanalytic critiques of the
religious process,
I think that they radically
underestimate the fundamental utility
and power of the underlying process.
Because you can become cynical about it
and talk about it in terms of the
imposition of a superstitious belief
system.
And you can talk about it in terms of
class struggle and patriarchy and,
and all of those things.
But I,
and I,
I think that those are valid in so far
as everything that human beings do,
our arc,
everything's,
all of the things that human beings do
are contaminated with those motives.
But I think it's a dreadful mistake to
write off the entire rhe entire
metaphysical history of mankind by
attributing it,
by attributing its existence to some
cause and then to make that cause
something that cynical and,
and destructive.
I think it's extremely dangerous.
And I think by doing that,
we risk losing what we actually need to
survive.
Because I think that the sorts of things
that,
that the metaphysical speculations that
are buried in religious systems teach us
are there are absolutely vital.
You cannot live properly without,
you'll become destructive or,
or suffer from some variety of serious
existential metaphysical or mental
illness.
I mean,
I've certainly observed in my clinical
practice that one of the major
contributors to mental illness,
it's certainly not the only one,
but,
and a physical illness is the tendency
for people to deceive and betrayed.
Other.
In fact,
I don't think there is any factor that
plays itself out in human interactions
that has more of a causal connection
with what we describe as mental illness,
that then tendency of people to lie to
each other and betray each other.
And one of the things that's really
shocking and surprising to me as a
clinician is that those sorts of things
are almost never considered as factors
in the etl etiology of mental illness.
So you know,
when you talk to someone in
psychotherapy and you're trying to
straighten out their lives,
basically what you're trying to do is to
replace falsehood with truth.
Now it isn't like you do that by telling
the person what the truth is and having
them accept that as some sort of final
ideological statement.
What you do instead is engaged with the
person in a form of dialogue that's
designed to help them understand exactly
what it was that happened and why it
happened and what was good about it and
what wasn't good about it and how the
things that we're good could continue to
manifest themselves in the future and
maybe to manifest themselves more
powerfully and more strongly and more
comprehensively in the future then they
had in the past.
And as far as I can tell,
that's basically what you're doing in
psychotherapy.
And I think all the evidence points in
that direction.
And I think you can do it for yourself.
I mean one of the things that young said
about psychotherapy,
about psychoanalytic psychotherapy was
that it could be replaced by a
sufficient moral effort.
So okay,
so what happens is that once God makes
man and woman,
so what that means in some sense is that
once the logo's is embodied in something
that's in something that's flash,
a place for that to be has to be
established.
And so you might say,
well,
what is the,
this is the narcan simple story.
So the question is,
well,
what is the architectural nature of
humanity?
The essential nature?
And the story says,
the essential nature of humanity is that
we are logos closed in flesh.
And I think that that's in court in
accordance with people's own subjective
experience.
I believe that's how we experience the
world because we s we see ourselves and
perceive ourselves as conscious beings
who are capable of transforming
potential into reality and that were
clothed,
embodied in something that's mortal and
corruptible and partly the opportunity
of existence and partly it's peril and
burden.
And then the question,
and this is actually the question that's
posed in the story of Adam and Eve,
is what then can be done about that?
What are the consequences of that and
what can be done about it?
And I think that the biblical writings
take it in as a,
as a comprehensive unit are an attempt,
are the attempt or one of the prime
attempts of mankind to sort out that
question and answer it over a period of
thousands and thousands and thousands of
years.
So,
so the first idea is that we're made in
the image of God and that what God is is
the thing that extracted order from
chaos at the beginning of time and that
we can,
that we partake in that and embody that
as we move through life and that we can
choose how to turn potential into
actuality and that we actually choose
what kind of reality the potential will
be turned into.
I think that part of the reason that
many cultures have the idea of heaven
and hell as well as the idea of the
underworld is that the archetipal
potential poles for the transformation
of potentiality are heaven and hell.
If things went as badly as they possibly
could,
we could turn the,
we could turn being itself to something
that as closely enough resembles hell.
So there's no reason to figure,
there's no reason to assume that there's
any distinction whatsoever.
And I think we've had a good taste of
that.
We had a very good taste of that in the
20th century.
And on the opposite pole is whatever we
could do,
if we made things as good as they could
possibly be now,
I think in order to make things as good
as they possibly can be,
you have to abandon your fear and your
resentment.
And there's lots of reasons why people
can't do that.
And some of the primary reasons have to
do with the fact of are the nature of
our being itself,
which is that we're,
we're conscious cocreators of reality,
but were invalid in a corruptible
envelope and that's painful and
frightening and,
and in some sense of sufficient mystery
to undermine our faith in the entire
process.
I mean,
then that happens to people all the
time,
especially when they get sick or when
things really go badly for them.
They wonder,
you know,
what's the point?
Or I was talking to one of my clients
the other day about Ivan in the brothers
Karamozov and I don't know if you've
read the brothers Karamazov,
but you definitely should.
It's an amazing book in that book.
There's a no novice,
a monastery novice named a Losha and he
has an older brother named Ivan.
And Alicia isn't very verbal,
but he's a very good person and he's
trying his best to be divine,
I suppose to be devout and to become a
monk.
But his older brother who's
extraordinarily intelligent and
charismatic is a rationalist right to
the core.
And he likes to torment a Losha with all
the reasons why.
Believing in some kind of divine reality
is weak,
naive and,
and uh,
ill advised.
And basically he tells,
he continually tells him stories about
horrible things that happen in the world
and attempts to force your Losha to
justify how if being is good,
those things could possibly occur.
It.
So one of the stories he tells the low
Hsa,
which is a story that Dostoyevsky got
from the newspapers of the time,
was that it's a story about a little
girl whose parents locked her in and out
house overnight when it was like
freezing outside.
And she screamed and cried the entire
night because she was locked out there
and eventually froze to death.
And that became quite a,
you know,
a scandal in Russia at that time.
And Ivan's basic comment Losha was that
as far as he was concerned,
the entire course of being up to this
point in time wasn't worth that girls
suffering that night.
And that there was no way that that
could be justified by man nor beast and
in and fall under the rubric of the
assumption that,
you know,
being was good and that what all
whatever created it was also good.
And so why even is very good at laying
out stories like that.
And you know,
I losha has a very difficult time
dealing with it and I think Dostoyevsky
had his finger on exactly the problem.
You want me to just like if,
if,
if life has some sort of transcendent
meaning,
then why is it pervaded by suffering and
evil?
That's basically the question that
people have been asking since the
beginning of time.
Um,
my,
my impression of the ad,
my feeling about that is that it's a
work in progress so to speak and the
things might be as good as they can be
because no one has figured out how to
make them any better than they are.
No,
I mean that,
that fault flies in the face of ideas
of,
you know,
the classical ideas of God or that God
is omniscient,
omnipotent,
omnipresent and um,
I always forget the other one.
Yes.
Right.
So the,
the classic attributes of God it is that
he has all the power there is,
and then of course the question is,
is if that's the case,
then why are things such a mess?
You know,
when there's been various attempts to
address that in the history of
metaphysical and philosophical thought.
And one is that they're very,
they live,
they vary in degrees of complexity.
But one is that,
you know,
the world is set up such that human
beings have to find their own way.
That we have a role to play in this in
some sense.
Although God could fix it if,
if he wished.
The other reason that there was a,
something went wrong near the beginning
of time when when people became,
or at least the beginning of human time
when people became self conscious and
that it's never been rectified.
And the other is,
and this is how it appears to me,
is that
yeah,
it's something that has to be worked out
as time progresses,
that the nature of perfection can't be
predetermined.
It's too complex.
And so in some sense that the whole,
that being itself is,
it is an attempt to compute the perfect
final solution,
but that no one knows what that is and
that you can't compute it without
running it as a simulation.
It's something like that.
And then we in that,
and I believe that every time people
make a choice that the choice that you
make is between tilting the world war,
tilting the world in the direction whose
final destination would be something
resembling hell or tilting the world in
a direction whose final destination
would be something approximating heaven.
And that you're always making that
decision and that you actually know that
you're making that decision,
that you make it consciously at that
point in time.
And so I think then part of the,
the,
the moral duty of people is to put their
lives together so that they're
sufficiently without arrogance and
sufficiently without resentment.
So that every time they make a choice,
they choose to push things in the right
direction,
that they're not vengeful and,
and angry and they're not out for
destruction and,
and,
uh,
um,
revenge.
You know,
and,
and the part of the reason that I've
come to this solution is because I've
read what people who are extremely
destructive think.
You know,
and I,
I you,
you can find those writings in various
places,
some of the most illuminating forms of
those writings.
I saw for example,
in the writings of the kid who shot up
the columbine high school and like he
tells you exactly what he was thinking.
It's very,
very clear and it's completely
metaphysical.
He explains it didn't religious
language.
He basically says that the world has
presently constituted it has is so evil
and so rife with suffering,
uh,
including all of humanity that it would
be better if it was just wiped out.
And that's what he proceeds to try to
do.
You know?
And,
and his,
his viewpoint is of course contaminated
by the fact that he places himself not
only above all other people but above
God himself and then proceeds to be the
judge and executioner.
And I don't see how you can read what he
said and not come to that conclusion.
That's just exactly what he says.
And the,
the connection between that and the,
the,
the nature of the satanic impulse to
rationally dominate and destroy are so
close that they could be,
they could've been formulated by the
same thinker.
And in some sense,
I think they were.
So now when God makes man and a woman
that,
a couple of things we talked about last
time that I think are extremely
interesting is that despite that the
fact that this book is so ancient,
one of the propositions that it
formulates is that both men and women
are formulated in the image of God,
which I think is quite remarkable.
One of the things you always hear with
regards to,
especially to radical feminist thought,
which is something that I am I think is
destructive beyond comprehension,
is that prior to the emergence of
feminist thinking,
the entire structure of humanity was
basically patriarchal and aimed at
oppressing women.
And I don't think you can.
And that was a certainly the case for
religious traditions like the,
like the great monotheisms,
but I don't think that you can read
genesis and come to that conclusion
because one of the first statements is
that both men and women are divided in
their fundamental essence.
And that is by no means of patriarchal
statement.
I think it's actually a miraculous
statement in some sense that that idea
could have been formulated so early in
time.
And I think that says more about the
true nature of the historical
relationship between men and women than
any attempt to rewrite history across
somebody illogical using some
ideological,
a priority idiot logical format.
So men and women are both created and
then they're created in the nae,
in the image of God,
whatever that means.
I think it means that they have the
capacity to turn possibility into
actuality and that that's built into our
being and then they're placed in the
garden.
Now the idea of a garden is a very,
very complicated idea because the garden
of Eden is,
is a particular type of place and what
it seems to me to be is that the story
is not only are describing archetipal
what men and women are,
but it's also describing archetipal Lee
what the environment of men and women
has to be and the environment has to be
a garden and a walled garden.
An Eden means well watered place in para
days.
I means Paradise Means Wald,
Wald,
guard.
And so the,
the idea that the idea that the semantic
indicators point to is that the proper
place for human beings is a place that's
a combination of culture and nature
because the walls are there to protect
and to keep in and to keep out where's
the garden itself is the,
you know,
the,
the flourishing of nature in some
independent manner.
Well also under the,
um,
what under the conscious apprehension
and shaping of the,
of the inhabitants of that particular
place.
And I think that that's part of what
human beings are struggling with right
now.
We're in the 21st century and a big part
of what faces us is,
well,
it appears that we have the ability
whether we want it or not,
to shape the manner in which the entire
planet manifest itself over the next
endless span of time.
And we're,
we're caught at the moment trying to
decide exactly what that should look
like and whether we want the
responsibility or not.
It seems to be honest.
And I would say that since it's on us,
we should wake up and take the
responsibility because the thing will
deteriorate of its own accord.
And that means we have difficult
decisions to make.
And at the moment we're mostly fighting
about who's bad and who's good within
that entire struggle and looking for
people to blame about why it's not as
perfect as it could be.
It's like there's a lot of reasons it's
not as perfect as it could be.
And I think that one of the most
fundamental reasons is that none of your
lives or as perfect as you could make
them.
And so because of that,
you're not in any position to make the
appropriate decisions that would have to
be made in order to set the world on its
proper course because it's a very
complicated set of decisions.
And that if you make a mistake because
you're ideologically predisposed or
because your life is full of deceit and
and inadequacy,
all of which you could conceivably
addressed,
then why would,
do you think that you would be reliable
enough to make the kind of decisions
that would set things right?
It's very,
very complicated and you know,
if we want to put the world in order,
we're going to have to extend our
capacity tremendously because we're just
not up to the task at the moment.
It's not only that people won't do it,
it's not only that people actively fight
against making things better.
It's also that we just don't know what
to do and it's a massive problem.
So,
and I don't believe that it's a problem
that you can solve unless you put your
own house together to begin with because
I don't think that you have the
psychological sophistication or the
spiritual stability to begin to address
such issues before you are standing on
firm ground firm ground that you've
placed beneath your own feet and it's no
simple matter to get your own life
together and then it's no simple matter
to get your own life together while
you're similar caneously getting your
family's life together and then there's
you and your family and your community
and all those things have to be brought
into harmony.
One of the things that I've been very,
very impressed with over the years is is
piaget's idea of and equilibrated state.
I think that that's,
I think that that's the appropriate
paradisical vision.
Now what piaget basically said was that
it was possible to set up complex
systems so that they were voluntarily
self sustaining and so across,
so at voluntarily self sustaining would
mean self sustaining.
Now they would mean self sustaining for
you it would,
it means self sustaining for you and the
people around you.
It would mean self sustaining for you
and the people around you.
Now next week,
next month,
the year after that and then across
multiple spans of time and there's a
kind of a harmonious balance that that
implies that I think you have to build
from the bottom up because it's too damn
complicated.
Otherwise you just don't,
you just don't know what the appropriate
next step would be and that and the
ability to determine what the next step
would be requires certain fundamentals.
It requires certain fundamental skills,
skills that have to be brought to bear
on the problem in order to solve the
problem.
One of them would be,
if you and I,
for example,
want to sit together and determine how
to establish and equilibrated space
right here and now,
one of the things that we have to do is
we have to be able to listen to each
other and we may have to be able to
listen to each other in such a way that
I,
if I happen to be better at articulating
myself than you are,
then I have to lend you my skills of
articulation to help you understand what
you want so that we can actually discuss
how we could mutually obtain our,
our,
our individual goals simultaneously in
the same space.
It's very complicated,
you know?
And that would also mean that you have
to know what you want.
And I think that in order for you to
know what you want,
you have to know who you are.
And if you have to know who you are,
that means you also have to know who you
are.
All right.
All the way down to the,
you know,
to the bottom of the demonic side,
which is no easy thing to do
because it's,
it's,
it's bottomless Lee,
terrible.
But if you don't take it into account,
then what you have is an equilibrated
solution that's unstable and naive and
that's not going to be helpful because
the parts of you that you haven't called
in to the table so to speak,
are going to rebel and cause all sorts
of trouble.
And so to some degree that means that
you have to make peace with this side of
you.
That's,
that's,
uh,
predatory and destructive in order to
bring that element into the discussion
so that it can be incorporated into the
solution that's going to propagate it
across time.
And you know,
you might think these are metaphysical
considerations and that they're very
abstract,
but I can tell you they're not.
When,
when,
when you people set up your intimate
relationships with one another,
you know,
your,
your marriages,
we'll say for the time being,
okay.
Unless you,
it managed to incorporate the elements
of your own psyche that are aggressive
and sexually demanding.
Let's say you're not going to set up a
marriage that is the least bit
satisfying or stable and it isn't
obvious at all how monstrous an awful,
both the husband and the wife have to be
across time so that they find each other
mutually satisfying.
But the idea that you can live as you
know,
naive persona together happily over any
length of time is completely absurd.
It just will not happen because the
parts of you that are deeply animalistic
and powerful are going to go off and
have their own adventure at times when
you win for you,
it's going to be the least convenient.
Okay,
so,
so back to the garden.
Well,
the garden seems to be something like
the optimal balance of nature and
culture.
And so the,
the genesis story is offering the
proposition that the proper environment
for human beings is actually partly
constructed and partly spontaneous.
Right?
And that is what a garden is like,
right?
Because a garden does what it wants to
do and it's also the product of billions
of years of evolution.
But when you're in the garden,
you're tending it and shaping it and
protecting it and walling it in so that
you get the advantages of the,
of the spontaneity that the natural
world can produce along with the
intelligent and judicious order that
heightened consciousness and attention
can bring to the situation.
And so the story basically says that the
human environment is half constructed
and half natural.
And that seems to me to be approximately
correct.
I mean we are cultural creatures.
We're not going back to the jungle.
No one wants to and no wonder because
it's full of snakes and poisonous
spiders and you live 30 years and like
it's not pleasant.
So that isn't us where culture and
nature at the same time.
So,
so then the question is,
well,
what exactly is the proper garden?
So I wrote this.
A walled garden is a productive,
natural place given order by structure.
That's,
it is a localized replication of the
interplay of chaos and order.
The man who's a kenotic logos,
there's this idea of Christianity.
It's a very strange idea because one of
the propositions of Christianity was
that God became man.
And so there's this idea that there's
the possibility of direct unity between
whatever the divine,
whatever the total consciousness of
being might be at any individual person.
And one of the questions that of course,
that particularly the Catholics tortured
themselves with as a consequence of that
piece of doctrine was how could God
possibly fit himself into the frame of a
human being without blowing it into,
into shattered bits.
And the basic idea that the Catholics
came up with was that God underwent
Kenosis,
which was a kind of emptying.
And so he emptied himself to the point
where there was only enough left of him
that he could fit inside a body without
blowing it into pieces.
And I think what that means in some
sense is that the consciousness that
each of us,
each of us has within us is a reflection
of the divine consciousness.
But it's scaled down to the point where
it can inhabit this sort of framework
that we constitute without,
without overwhelming it,
without destroying it.
And so the idea is that Adam and eve are
these kinds of reduced divine
consciousness and that they inhabit a
microcosm of chaos and order.
So it's like a localized representation
of the entire structure of via.
And I think that that's perfectly
reasonable because I do believe that
it's perfectly appropriate for each of
you to assume that what you inhabit in
your own being is a microcosm of the
entirety.
What else could it possibly be?
Especially if you take seriously the
proposition that what being is
constructed of is,
is chaos and order.
That's what you have in front of you is
chaos and order.
And maybe you have just the right amount
of it in front of you so that you could
bring it into a harmonious relationship.
I mean you,
you better or,
or your or there's going to be hell to
pay.
So it's not like it's optional.
So what's optional is whether you accept
the responsibility of doing it.
That's what I think is optional.
I also think that that's why people
won't wake up.
You know,
because there's been a story throughout
the entire history of mankind since we
became conscious that people could wake
up,
they could become enlightened,
but they don't.
And you know,
you,
you hear people,
especially the new age people and,
and I think they were sort of motivated
to begin with by Joseph Campbell and
maybe by the human potential people that
if you just follow your bliss,
that you could wake up.
And I think that that's,
I understand why that idea emerged.
It's,
it's a classic 1960s idea,
which is that you could have heaven with
no responsibility whatsoever just by
doing what felt good all the time.
You know,
and I think there's a kernel of truth in
it.
But the problem with the whole idea is
that there's no responsibility in it at
all.
And I think that if you wake up,
the problem with waking up is that you
have to take responsibility.
And then the question might be,
well,
how much responsibility do you have to
take?
An answer to that might be,
it depends on how much you want to wake
up because if you want to wake up
completely,
maybe then you have to take
responsibility for the whole thing.
I think that's what it means.
There's this old idea in Christianity
that Christ took the sins of the world
on his shoulders and that's a very
strange idea and what Christianity has
done with that idea to some degree has
made the proposition that because Christ
took the sins of the world on his
shoulders and died for us as a
consequence that everything has been
redeemed.
But the problem with that,
and this is the problem that you pointed
out when he was talking about the
development of science from Alchemy,
is that everything doesn't seem to have
been redeemed.
There's still plenty of problems.
Part of the reason that you and believe
that alchemy developed into science in
Europe was because the Christian
community realized at an unconscious
level that the proposition that reality
had been redeemed by the death of Christ
was an incomplete assumption because it
didn't seem to be working.
And so there was a tremendous emphasis
on spiritual development and
Christianity and,
and the idea of the,
of the death redeeming humanity was a
spiritual idea,
but it left the material world behind as
something that was essentially damned
and young's idea was that the unredeemed
material world was crying out.
And human beings,
especially in Europe responded to that.
And the way they responded to that was
by beginning to dream the
transformations of the material world
could bring about the redeemed state.
And that that was the motivating dream
that led to the emergence of science.
You know,
and if you don't have a better theory
for why science emerged,
that's a pretty damn good one.
And,
you know,
young spent a lot of time trying to
figure that out.
And uh,
you know,
it strikes me as something that's very
much the case.
So maybe that part of niches commentary
was the Christianity lost its moral
forest because it,
it,
it continually pushed paradise off to a
place that was beyond death and
alleviated the responsibility of all the
individuals who were currently alive.
It alleviated their responsibility to
bring it about.
And maybe that's why the whole damn
thing came crashing down.
It's like,
it,
it lost its moral footing.
I mean,
niches are often regarded as perhaps the
most influential antichristian who ever
lived.
But I have always read him as a
salutary,
um,
corrective.
You know,
if something's rotten,
something that goes in there and
destroys the rod is actually it's
friend,
not it's enemy.
And I think that that was the role that
[inaudible] played in relationship to
Christianity.
He thought that as soon as it had
disappeared into some other world than
it had lost its moral right to exist
because it left everything behind.
It's like the Buddhist doctrine that you
can attain nirvana,
you know,
individually.
And that's what you should be doing.
You should detach yourself from
existence and attain Nirvana.
Existence in and of itself can go to
hell.
It's like it's not a very,
it's not a very,
uh,
yeah,
it's an irresponsible,
it's irresponsible doctrine.
You know,
Buddha himself left nervana to come back
to redeem humanity.
He decided he,
and one of his most fundamental
temptations was the gods offered him the
opportunity to stay in paradise and he
left that dose so that he could come
back,
so to speak,
and spread his teachings around to try
to bring everything else up to the state
of being redeemed.
So I don't think that the idea that you
can escape as a reasonable idea,
I think it's a running away from
responsibility.
So
walled garden is a productive,
natural place given order by structure.
Thus,
it's a localized replication of the
interplay of chaos and order.
The man who's a keynotek logos says,
place there to inhabit and keep it the
fact that the garden may be also a well
watered place into meets the same water.
The primal element commonly represents
fertility and generative chaos.
However,
the garden itself is tended structured
and ordered.
Thus,
a garden is both productive and
sheltered,
particularly if it is walled.
And well-watered throughout the garden
is a microcosm of being.
It is in turn the place of man,
female and male who are microcosms of
logos.
So I would say what,
what that story suggests is that the
entire destiny of being itself is played
out in a microcosmic form in the
localized environments that every human
being in habits.
And I think that's a perfectly
reasonable way of looking at it.
And I can't see how it could be any
other way.
Next,
the garden and the tree and the Lord God
planted a garden,
eastward and Eden.
And there he put the man who even with
whom he had formed and out of the ground
made the Lord God to grow every tree
that is pleasant to the sight and good
for food,
the tree of life also in the midst of
the garden and the tree of the knowledge
of good and evil.
Now the whole tree idea,
it's insanely complicated.
I mean,
the first thing that you might think
about with regards to trees is that we
spend a bloody long time in them during
our evolutionary history,
tens of millions of years.
So the idea that that being is a tree
and if there are snakes in the tree and
around the bottom of the tree was
literally true for us for some tens of
millions of years.
And I think I talked to you about um,
Lynn,
Isabelle and her hypothesis about snakes
and vision.
You know,
her basic answer,
biological hypothesis is that it was the
arms race between our tree dwelling
ancestors and predatory snakes that gave
human beings incredible vision that we
have.
And that's exactly the story that's laid
out in the genesis story because it's
the snake that gives Adam and eve vision
and strangely enough to snake gives Adam
and eve enough vision so that the scales
fall from the rise and so that they can,
that they wake up and re and re realize
that they're naked.
And you know,
that seems to me to be a story.
Imagine that we became more and more
okay
cognitively and attention Lee complex as
a consequence of being chased by
something that was evolving along with
us.
So that's an evolutionary arms race.
That sort of thing happens in evolution
all the time.
And then in order to outsmart the snake,
we had to grow brain that was so big
that something catastrophic happened.
And the catastrophic occurrence was that
we became so aware of the nature of
being end up our own being that we could
start to see its limits.
You know,
human beings can envision time.
It's something that distinguishes us,
I think completely from other animals
because we can see the future,
we can see multiple potential futures.
And of course that's a massive advantage
because that means that we can see
terrible futures and strive to avoid
them.
But it also means that we can see
inevitably terrible future.
So for example,
you know that even if you're not hungry
now,
you're going to be hungry in the future.
And even if you're not ill now,
you're going to be ill in the future.
And that even though you're not old now,
you're going to be old in the future.
And not the same as the case for
everyone that you know.
And then everything decays and goes
away.
And so that I think is what genesis
portrays as the fall.
And I don't think there's any doubt
about it.
I think if you read the story,
I mean people have been reading this
story for a very long period of time,
but to me it makes the case about as
straightforwardly as any story possibly
could.
So
now more about the tree.
Also,
there's the evolutionary tree and the
evolutionary tree has the snake in it
and the evolutionary tree also bears
fruit.
And do you know that our color vision
evolved to detect ripe fruit?
And I think the part of the reason that
eve
temps
Adam towards consciousness is because
women shared fruit with men.
And sharing food is a very,
very weird thing.
I mean,
most mammals share food with their
offspring,
right?
So most other mammals will share food
with their infants,
but human beings are very peculiar in
that we'll share food with each other
and we share food with strangers and
it's built into us.
This isn't some cultural construct,
human being share food.
In fact,
if we don't eat communally,
our whole ability to regulate our eating
goes a strain,
get sick.
And we know perfectly well that our
vision evolved to detect ripe fruit
because one of the things we're really
good at is detecting the difference
between red and green and the
relationship between fruit and evolution
and women and consciousness is so tight
that even many of the attributes that
men find beautiful in women,
our fruit like attributes.
So it's an old and deep association.
And I think part of the reason that
women,
the way women tempted men towards self
consciousness is imagine that you're
more self conscious if you're
vulnerable.
And so I think that the idea that women
became self conscious first is probably
right because women first of all had to
contend with the fact that they were
small and easily damaged.
But even more particularly,
they had to contend with the fact that
they had infants who were small and
easily damaged.
And I think that female nervous systems
have actually evolved so that they're,
they're optimized for the,
for the female infant dyad and not for
the female herself.
Because you might ask,
well,
why are women more sensitive to negative
emotion and higher in agreeableness than
men?
And it makes perfect sense.
I mean there's a lot of reasons why it
might be,
but it particularly makes perfect sense
if the nervous system that women are
using is adapted so that it's responding
to the world as as if the woman is a
dyad between her and her infant,
which is exactly how she's going to have
to act if she's going to get an infant
from the age of,
well zero to four certainly,
but we could say from zero to 14,
it's a hell of a burden.
It's the biggest maternal burden that
any creature on the planet caries.
And for some,
in some manner,
women were able to entice men into pr,
into,
um,
dyadic pair bonds.
And there's a variety of reasons why
that might be.
Some of the evolutionary biologists
think it's because women are continually
sexually available,
which makes them unique among about most
animals and certainly unique among
primates so that it made sense from a
sexual perspective persec perspective
for a man to bind himself to one woman
because men are rather,
they have a strong sex drive and
they're,
they tend towards,
um,
they certainly as a general rule want to
have sexual relationships more often
than the typical woman.
But women are capable of doing that.
And women share food and women are
gatherers.
And so the idea that women enticed men
into self consciousness by sharing food
with them strikes me as highly probable
they,
that's an enticement.
And I think that women did make men self
conscious and I think they did it a
whole bunch of ways.
I mean I think they first did it by
making men more and more aware of how
vulnerable women and children were and
and drawing their attention to the fact
that in principle that placed a moral
responsibility on the man.
You know,
we think of that as self evident now,
but it's certainly not self self evident
in the animal kingdom.
So it's a,
it's a particularly human discovery.
And then I also think that women made
men self conscious by rejecting them
constantly.
And so what that also means is that
women produced an evolutionary arms race
in some sense among men and between men
and women.
Because one of the things we have to
account for you remember,
is are incredibly rapid cortical growth.
Okay.
You know,
and it seems to me that our whole
variety of positive feedback loops got
going at the same time.
And that's what produced a tremendous
increase in our cortical capacity up to
the point where we became aware of our
own vulnerability.
And that was the birth of self
consciousness.
Now,
one of the things that's very interested
interesting in genesis is that genesis
portrays the emergence of self
consciousness as something so profound
that it produced a cataclysmic rift in
the structure of being,
you know,
and now of course,
whether or not you believe that depends
on what you think of as being,
but the idea,
I mean,
you think about the relationship that
human beings have with being,
I mean,
first of all,
we don't really see ourselves as part of
the natural world.
We see ourselves as somehow separate
from the natural world.
We also see ourselves.
It's so funny because most modern people
believe that the doctrine of original
sin is an absurd doctrine.
But I don't think I've ever met a modern
person who isn't fully convinced of the
doctrine of original sin.
I mean,
all you have to do is talk to an
environmentalist for 15 seconds and the
first thing they'll tell you is that
there's something intrinsically corrupt
about human beings and that we're
running around destroying the planet.
I mean,
how you can fail to see that as a modern
transformation of the idea of original
sin is beyond me.
The idea that there's something wrong
with people is the idea of original sin.
So,
and,
and do people not believe that?
I mean,
who in this room feels that they're
everything they could be or who in this
room feels that they're not in some
sense of fallen being?
I mean,
I've,
I've never met anyone who doesn't fit
into that category.
The closest you ever get is somebody
who's like psychopathic beyond belief.
You know,
and I mean,
people are burdened by their
inadequacies to different degrees,
but virtually no one is virtually no one
is secure enough to stand forth as the
flawed beating they are and say,
well,
everything's the way it should be with
me.
So how the hell do you account for that?
Now I think,
I don't exactly know what the situation
is,
but it seems to me,
so one of the things that happens,
I'll get back to the tree in the minute,
is that okay?
The serpent tap tamps,
he first of all to eat the tree of the
fruit of the knowledge of good and evil,
which is quite interesting.
So it's the knowledge of good and evil.
So there's two trees,
right?
There's the tree of life and there's the
tree of the knowledge of good and evil.
And it's not good and bad.
It's good and evil,
and it's the serpent that tempts eve to
take the fruit.
Okay.
So we've already talked about the
potential role of the serpent and the
development of visual apprehension and
the fact that human beings cognitive
structure is primarily visual and that
we have the best visual system of any
primate on the planet and a better
visual system that anything but birds.
And that that's tightly tied with our
ability to see.
And that fact that we can see and pay
attention appears to be tightly tied
with our ability to detect their own
vulnerability.
I mean,
it's,
it's a fair,
it's a pretty coherent story.
Now what happens after Adam and eve eat
fruit?
It's,
it's,
it's very,
very complicated and happens in,
it's a very,
it's very interesting the way the story
portrays it because it's all packed
together in almost no words.
So what happens?
The serpent first tells eve,
if you eat this fruit,
you won't die because that's what God
has said.
Don't eat that thing or you'll die for
God knows that in the day that you eat
thereof,
then your eyes shall be opened and ye
shall be as gods knowing good and evil.
Now that's very interesting because the
first thing that happens is that there's
an intimation that whatever
transformative process occurs,
and as a consequence of this,
of this meal,
we'll elevate human beings further to
the godlike status.
It's now it's strange because they've
already been attributed that to some
degree in the story,
right?
Because they're made in the image of
God.
But there's an intimation here that
because of what happens as the
transformation is that human beings
prior to eating the fruit did not see
properly and they weren't aware of the
fact that they were naked.
Now that you can derive that conclusion
by noticing that that's what happens to
them when they do eat the fruit.
So,
and then so,
so there's this intimation that human
beings are at a certain plane of being
that that plane of being could be
elevated in terms of power,
that one of the consequences of that
elevation would be all of a sudden that
people became mortal beings.
And so what that also means is that the
unconscious paradise,
primary Pri prior to the emergence of
self consciousness is,
um,
it's,
it's a,
it's an amoral existence.
And so the way that that's being dealt
with historically is to assume that the
conditions in the garden of Eden,
we're sort of like the conditions of
animal unconsciousness because animals
aren't beyond good and evil.
They're just not in the domain of good
and evil.
And then you might ask,
well,
why is that?
What is there something particular about
the knowledge of good and evil?
Now,
you know,
modern people don't really believe in
the idea of evil or in the idea of good,
so they don't really ask questions like
that.
But I think the story sheds clear light
on exactly what this means.
If you have a question.
No.
Okay.
So yes.
Yeah.
Bit more about like what do you think
that means that they didn't,
that there had to be that extra level of
like thoughts even though they already
had the,
they were made in the image.
Well I think it has to do with the
difference between consciousness and
self consciousness because I think what
happens initially is that creatures are
conscious but they're not self
conscious.
Now you might ask,
well what is self conscious mean?
Well it's complicated,
right?
Because there is some evidence from the
animal experimental literature that
animals have rudimentary self
consciousness.
So there's,
I think self consciousness is a
multifactorial construct.
It's not like something that's
reflective and automatic.
You're self conscious in that you know
that you exist and that you have some
sense of your boundaries and that you
have some sense of who and what you are.
But you're not fully self conscious
because you don't know exactly who or
what you are and you don't know what
your possibilities are.
Limitations are and you don't know what
your essential nature is.
So,
and part of the reason that you're self
conscious is because you're the
inheritor of a cultural tradition.
It's linguistically predicated that
contains information about what human
beings are like that has been worked on
by collective generations of human
beings over thousands and thousands of
years.
Right?
So partly the reason you're self
conscious is because you're educated and
there's no real limit to that.
You come to university to become more
self conscious.
So it's complicated,
but there's an initial self
consciousness that seems to be the
precipitating event.
And I think it's reasonable to assume
that that's associated with cortical
expansion and the development of
enhanced cognitive ability.
I mean,
I don't think that that's a questionable
assumption.
Everybody just just makes theK or as if
that's the case.
We're intelligent enough to have
discovered time.
And the problem with discovering time,
which is the fourth dimension,
we're,
we're minimally extendable in time now.
We don't seem to be bothered by the fact
that we're minimally extendable in
space.
Right.
Because I mean here you are and you're
not over there.
And there are obviously limitations to
that and we do try to overcome them with
telephones and televisions and all of
our gadgets that put us everywhere at
once.
But,
but to discover our finitude in time is
to discover time and it's not surprising
that that's represented in this story as
a cataclysmic disjunction in the
structure of being.
That's how we experience it.
Something's wrong.
And I don't believe that that's how
animals experience being like they might
experience things that need to be done
temporarily to put things back into
proper balance,
but they're not set up to question the
nature of existence itself.
So anyways,
now.
Yup.
Is it possible that means the story is
or historical production back to
literary in literature or history of,
I think it's both.
No,
I think it's a description.
Architectural stories are true on
multiple levels at the same time.
So I think it's a file or genetic and an
Auntie genetic story simultaneously.
There's no reason it can't be.
So there is the paradise allow element
of childhood prior to the emergence of
self consciousness.
I can tell when my children learned they
were naked.
Actually it didn't bother my daughter at
all.
But my son,
you know who's quite an emotionally
stable person.
By the time he was two and a half likely
there is no damn way you were going in
the bathroom with him.
And if he wasn't closed he would not
show himself.
And as far as I could tell,
that was all his own doing because it
wasn't like we were hung up about that
and it didn't bother my daughter.
So it wasn't the familial environment
that was producing that he was in an
intensely private creature and that was
his own discovery.
And you know,
I mean part of the reason I think that
people are self conscious is that we
stand up right?
And that we're very,
very exposed to the world in a way that
most animals aren't.
But I also think there's more to it than
that too,
is that because we were self conscious,
we're also intensely aware of our own
inadequacies and imperfections and we're
not willing to share them with the world
except under very limited conditions.
And I would also say it's no wonder,
you know,
cause people run around talking about
how it would be better if we weren't
ashamed of our bodies.
It's like it's not exactly clear to me
that it would be better.
It's a pain in the neck,
but it makes you take care of them and
try to fix them.
You know,
if you had no sense that there was
something wrong,
why the hell would you try to fix it?
So I don't think you can have your cake
and eat it too.
You can't think,
oh,
I'm perfect just the way I am.
And then also be motivated to make
things better.
That's not possible.
Now you might be able to say the fact
that I'm away,
I'm the way I am is acceptable given my
plans to make things better,
which I think is perfectly reasonable.
You don't want to be so ashamed that
you're immobilized.
That seems counterproductive.
But the idea that people have nothing to
be ashamed of strikes me as naive beyond
belief.
So,
so anyways,
I do think it's onto genetic and Fila
genetic simultaneously.
And when the woman saw that the tree was
good for food and then it was pleasant
to the eyes and a tree to be desired to
make one wise,
she took of the fruit thereof and did
eat and gave also unto her husband with
her.
And he did eat and the eyes of both of
them were open and they knew they were
naked and they sewed fig leaves together
and made themselves aprons.
And there's an awful lot of information
packed into those few lines.
So the first is,
is that it's the woman,
the woman precipitates this.
And I believe that that's the case.
I think that that,
I think that women still make men self
conscious.
And I think they do that because of
their vulnerability,
because of their vulnerability infants,
but also because they're incredibly
harsh judges of men.
So we know,
for example,
from the,
from the dating site studies that women
regard 85% of men is below average in
physical appearance.
So,
and we also know that the default
response to a woman in,
in,
in response to a mating request is,
are you kidding?
So,
and there's nothing that makes more men
more self conscious than that.
And you might say,
well what's the consequence of that?
And one is eternal enmity between the
sexes.
So women,
men hate women because they get rejected
all the time.
And that manifests itself in all sorts
of underground war against women.
And,
and in some cultures the is virtually
total and but it also manifests it in
men's attempts to continually make
themselves better so that they can
attract women.
And so,
you know,
there's no doubt that women with their
selective mating,
which is partly what makes them
different than chimpanzees have been a
major motivating force for the
development of culture status.
Turns out to be important to men.
And I think you can make a very strong
case that culture itself has been the
product of status competition in large
part be the consequence of status
competition between men driven by women.
So,
so anyways,
so they both eat the fruit and then
they're naked.
Now,
this is an interesting thing because as
I said,
the fruit is the fruit of the tree.
And the tree is a very,
very,
very complicated thing.
So it's,
it's,
uh,
the tree represents something that's
manifesting itself on multiple levels
simultaneously.
So as there,
there's the actual trees in which the
actual fruits grew and the actual fruits
that ripened.
And that sharpened our vision that gave
us color vision,
and that constituted a large part of our
diet.
And that we did forge for and share.
And then there's,
there's the metaphysical tree,
which is the tree that produced that
fruit that produced that,
that neurological transformation that
went along with that over the course of
evolution.
And then there's another tree that lurks
in there,
which is the tree that constitutes the,
the human being itself,
because we're also frequently symbolized
as trees.
And I think we're like,
we're,
it's the microcosm,
macrocosm tree that's reflected in the
Scandinavian figure of the world tree,
you know,
so that's a drizzle.
So you know that some of you have no
doubt watched the avengers and you see
that both Loki and thor come from,
um,
as guard and as guard is actually in the
branches of the Scandinavian world tree.
Now the question is,
what is the Scandinavian world tree?
Well,
it's even represented this way in the
movies.
The Scandinavian world tree isn't a tree
like a tree in the forest to
Scandinavian world.
Tree is the microcosm to macrocosm tree.
So it's like the subatomic realm and the
atomic realm and molecular realm and the
realm above that.
And then the phenomenal logical realm.
And then the cosmic realm emerging as a
set of stacked phenomena.
And the gods inhabit the upper reaches
of that tree.
And that's the same tree that the world
tree that's Sharman climb up and down
when they have their shamonic
transformation experiences,
which are usually initiated as a
consequence of their interactions with
hallucinogenic drugs,
often mushrooms and the Sharman report
that they die and decompose to skeletons
and then climb the world tree and enter
heaven.
And people like Eliana,
who were the,
some of the initial observers of the
shamonic phenomenon,
believed that the use of drugs was a
decadent,
um,
after consequence of a pure,
original tradition.
But the modern evidence suggests very
strongly that it's the use of the
psychedelic mushrooms in particular that
produced the death rebirth experience
and the climbing up and down the
microcosm to macrocosm tree.
There's been some very interesting
recent downturn,
logical research done on Sharman who use
Iowasca in the Amazon jungle.
And the tree they seem to climb up and
down is all the way down to the
molecular and all the way up to the
cosmic.
And there are people who have,
who believe,
who've given credence to the idea that
the shaman can go down far enough to see
DNA.
Now,
you know,
we don't know.
We have no idea what to make of those
sorts of reports.
But,
um,
I would be very hesitant about
dismissing them because the world's a
very weird place and there's nothing in
the world that stranger than psychedelic
drugs.
And people have been using those for
tens of thousands of years and a
tremendous number of our religious
traditions are a consequence of use of
hallucinogenic naturally occurring
hallucinogenic chemicals and they seem
to produce profound transformations of
consciousness and profound enough so
that we have no idea what to make of
them.
So that the tree is a very,
very complicated thing.
And it seems to me,
you know,
inside a cathedral,
you know the pillars and the columns,
those are tree like structures,
especially in the gothic cathedrals.
They look almost exactly like,
like the canopy of of old growth forests
and the trees that are in there are the
trees that we lived in tens of millions
of years ago,
but they're also the tree that's growing
up from the tiniest micro realm up to
the macro realm and attempting to
manifest itself in perfectly harmonious
layers at every single level of
structure all the way up.
And I think that part of what people are
doing when they practice things like
yoga and they're trying to get the
shockers,
so to speak,
aligned,
is that the shock was our like cross
sections of that tree at different
levels of emergence.
And the person who is practicing yoga is
trying to get their body aligned so that
the communication from the microcosmic
level to the macro cosmic level is
completely facilitated and free of
blockages.
So on.
I don't know if you know that when
people do yoga,
when they really know how to do it,
they don't do it does them.
So yoga happens to people spontaneously
when they wake up and the,
you know,
the Yogis talk about that as the
influence of the Kundalini serpent,
which is the thing that lives at the
base of the spine and when the Yogi is
sufficiently sophisticated in his
practice there the body moves by itself
and straightens itself out and aligns
itself along the central axis of being.
And if it's aligned properly,
that's when divine revelations will
occur.
And that's what you see manifested in
religious symbolism.
When you look at the figure of the
Buddha who sitting in this triangular
position and he's completely covered in
gold,
is that he's aligned his body,
the levels of the material being so
perfectly that the information flow
across the levels of,
of structure are without flaw.
And that puts them simultaneously in
contact with the microcosmic realm and
the macro cosmic realm.
So
all right,
so,
so the tree is a very,
very,
very complicated idea.
There's the tree that you are and
there's the tree that the cosmos itself
is.
And the third is the tree that we lived
in and there's the tree that bears fruit
and those are all the same tree from a,
from a broader perspective.
So your eyes are opened and they
realized they were naked.
I'm just wondering how this sort of ties
in with the time,
the realization of client,
where they immortal before that.
No,
but they,
they,
they had no set,
no concept of death.
Okay.
So that,
that's a very good question.
Well,
I think the absence of death prior to
the emergence of self consciousness,
I mean,
figuring out what death is is a very
tricky thing.
I mean,
one element of death is that you cease
to be as a physical form.
Well death for humans is a lot more than
that.
It's not only that you cease to exist as
a material for is your bloody well know
it.
And that's where death where,
that's where dance has it's primary
sting.
You know,
if there was,
if there was no apprehension of death,
it would be a lot less dramatic
experience than it actually is.
I mean,
it's complicated because if you look at
elephants,
elephants are,
are pretty self conscious.
They seem to be,
they seem to understand to some degree
what death means.
They will return to the place where an
elephant that they knew well died and
they will move the bones around.
And so they seem to be able to remember
the cessation of being over a very long
period of time.
But they certainly can't conceptualize
it the way we do because they don't have
any tools of conceptualization.
They're not linguistic.
So I think that the,
the,
the self,
the unselfconscious pre death paradise
is prior to self consciousness.
And it's the same state that,
that a child exists in before there,
before they are aware that they're
naked,
you know?
And that develops in,
in Russia's in some sense,
you know,
so,
all right.
So the eyes of both of them were opened
and they knew they were naked and they
sewed fig leaves together and made
themselves aprons.
Well,
that's a massive transformation in that
statement.
So first of all,
people figure out that they're naked.
Now you think,
well,
what does it mean to figure out that
you're naked?
Well,
generally that's red in a sexual sense.
And I think the sexual sense can't be
over.
Like it can't be ignored because I think
part of the way that people are
primarily self conscious is sexually,
right?
Because the most fundamental element of
being evaluated by another is evaluation
for sexual attractiveness.
And so,
you know,
men bear the burden of that because
they're constantly compared to other men
in terms of their accomplishments and
their position in the dominance
hierarchy.
And women bear the brunt of that because
they're constantly being compared to the
ideal feminine form.
And the ideal feminine form is
associated both with sexuality and with
reproduction.
And so there's no doubt that the,
the fact of a sexual ideal makes
everyone intensely self conscious.
Now you know,
if,
if you look at,
there are all sorts of attempts
constantly to write that off to cultural
factors.
You know,
to say that the reason that women are so
intensely concerned with their body
images because we've constructed false
cultural representations of beauty,
it's like I don't think there's any
evidence for that claim at all.
I mean there's plenty of evidence for
what is regarded as optimally healthy
and attractive with regards to women
cross.
Culturally there are variations in it.
So body size for example,
is one of the variations.
But body shape is very seldomly varied
and symmetry is virtually never varied.
And skin quality is never varied and
youth is never varied.
So there's plenty.
And,
and the reason those things appear to be
never varied is because they're good
markers of fertility and health and
across culture.
Men,
women like man who are higher up in the
dominance hierarchy.
And I think what women have done is
outsourced the problem of sexual
selection to competition among men.
So all they do is let men compete and
then peel off the top,
which is a perfectly reasonable,
it's an absolutely reasonable way of
solving the problem.
But what that does is make all the men
who were in the lower stratas of the
socioeconomic hierarchy intensely
self-conscious,
angry and resentful,
and they become like homicidal and
genocidal if things are pushed too far.
I mean,
Martin Daly and Margo Wilson have done a
perfectly reasonable job of laying out
the consequence of very unequal
societies on male aggression.
And what happens is that as the
probability that young men will be able
to climb up a dominance hierarchy
decreases the young men at the bottom
become increasingly murderous and
impulsive.
And it's,
it's not surprising.
Not only did they delineate that,
but they showed that the men who become
successfully impulsive,
aggressive,
and they did this most in their studies
of Chicago gang behavior actually push
themselves up the hierarchy fast enough
and far enough.
So they immediately become attractive to
women.
So the fact that they become impulsively
aggressive and even murderous,
it works.
So it's,
it's not,
it's not some side effect of some
process that's gone wrong.
It's what you do when the competition
pressures become so high that you can't
climb the hierarchy.
As a consequence,
they have diligent,
um,
application of prosocial behavior over
the long run.
Margo daily and,
and,
and uh,
Wilson,
Margo Wilson and he said Margo Wilson.
Yeah,
it's,
it's Margo Wilson and daily,
What's dailies name there at mcmaster?
Look Up David bus buses.
The best source for this.
He wrote a textbook on evolutionary
psychology.
It's a great book.
I mean,
mostly textbooks aren't great books,
but his textbook on evolutionary
psychology is great book.
And if you look at the sexual selection
chapters,
you know,
they're incredibly illuminating.
So you know,
the correlation between male
socioeconomic success and access to
sexual partners is like 0.5.
It's high.
It's the determining factor.
It's no joke.
And between,
for women it's zero.
So you know,
in that,
well,
that's how it is.
And so,
sorry.
Oh yeah.
Male aggression.
They looked at Chicago in particular,
what they found for example,
was in the Chicago gangs.
Um,
generally what happened because there
are very high rates of male on male
homicide in the Chicago gang scene and
it's usually interracial,
not cross racial and it's usually young
man against young men.
So you know,
you're much more likely to be killed by
murder if you're a young man then if
you're an older woman and although it's
the older women who are most afraid of
this sort of thing.
So young man who are always getting
killed by other young men.
And basically what Daly and Wilson
showed was that if you are a gang member
in Chicago and you were charged with
murder,
usually the murder was a consequence of
some kind of status,
um,
challenge.
So maybe it's gang member ray against
you and your gang member be while you're
fighting,
maybe you're both arms.
So he,
he's going to kill you.
Are you going to kill him?
It's a toss up.
You kill him.
Okay.
Then what happens?
Well,
no one testifies against you and you
plead,
you know,
they,
they nailed it.
They try to nail you for,
um,
for a homicide,
say second degree murder and you plead
self defense and they plea bargain it
down to manslaughter and they throw you
in jail for three years and you're out
in a year and a half on good behavior
and your status goes way up.
So it's a perfectly reasonable,
it's not a,
what would you call equilibrated
solution,
but the reasons for it are quite clear
and it works.
Have you ever seen the,
the evolutionary rap by the Canadian?
You know,
the one,
I mean,
it's great.
It's great.
I babba Babba what's his name?
Babba I don't remember.
Look it up.
Evolutionary rap.
It's brilliant.
He takes all of the evolutionary
psychology work that's been done over
the last 15 years and casts,
it's as a gangster rap song and it's
extraordinarily well done.
Jesus.
Don't you have anything better to do?
Martha Stewart?
She Ain't,
she spoke and she's very funny piece by
saying it's just them that basically
you're,
you're clearly edit for president.
So let me give you some.
Okay,
so she,
she cooks,
she proceeds to give these hilarious but
probably useful tests.
And at the end of that,
the crowds standing feet for her.
Well this is funny,
but I was,
I was puzzled by the finding of the
standing ovation.
But I think when you're talking about is
basically she had credit,
like she
female sexual fantasy is beauty and the
beast.
Now if you,
if you don't believe that you might give
some consideration to the phenomenal
popularity of 50 shades of grey.
Now why is that?
Well,
it's because women don't want a man who
isn't dangerous.
They want a man who's really dangerous
or who can be really dangerous,
but who,
who is capable of not being
so,
and that's closely allied with youngs
idea of the incorporation of the shadow.
So if you're,
if you're a developed as a male,
you should be too dangerous to mess
with,
but you should be civilized enough to
keep that under control.
And that's not the same as repression of
aggression and sexuality.
It's not the same at all.
That just means that you're still a five
year old boy.
That's the eatable outcome,
right?
Where the mother is so terrified of the
male movement towards dominance and
aggression that she squashes it
completely and keeps the the male at
unit level for the rest of his life
turning him into something that's like a
potato that's grown in the darkness,
in the,
in the basement.
You know,
with white tubers coming up everywhere
and resentful and murderous underneath
all that,
it's not a positive outcome.
You know,
it's associated with the destruction of
consciousness.
That's the oedipal story.
And like women are afraid of men because
they're monsters.
But the problem is,
is that for bidding a man to become a
monster just makes him a monster.
It drives it underground.
What has to happen is the men have to be
taught how to be civilized monsters and
we're doing a very bad job of that.
You know,
it's it and we're going to pay a big
price for it.
I think we're already paying a price for
it.
I mean,
one of the prices that seems to be being
paid in Japan is that people in Japan
don't have sex anymore.
So
maybe loaded someone try and frame it
well,
but um,
like their rape culture movement towards
educating men,
not to rape women.
He said of educating and how big
dialogue,
and I'm wondering how much,
what exactly you're talking about is
about incorporating sexuality and I'm
like women that affectual in a healthy
way so that it doesn't come out sort of
underground in the go violet.
Well,
at tremendous amount of the push to,
to and,
and the push behind the whole idea of
rape culture is violently anti male
movement.
The idea that there's a rape culture is
completely insane.
No men get together and say,
well,
I think we should go out and rape some
women,
especially not in,
in like relatively civilized western and
North American cultures,
Frat boys together to get women way too
drunk.
Yes,
yes.
But I understand that,
but that's more that I would say that
that's more a consequence of stupidity
and inability than anything else.
Women don't get together and do this.
You can't deny that that happened.
I can't deny that it happens,
but I can deny that it's a culture
correct title and that,
uh,
anyway,
well let's look,
I,
I don't want to know how to talk about
that,
but let's,
let's go back to it.
How am I going to say,
if you want to look at some literature
on that,
you slipped up gentry,
Macquarie,
Dr Dunkin security,
other interesting information about how
they might be trying to turn these are
any like and rubber line,
but like it's the Arab,
anybody in the house and like the of
brother had been covering for each
other.
Yeah.
It's all also one of the things that you
absolutely have to understand that no
alcohol means no rape.
Yeah.
So it's as simple as that.
I mean,
I studied the effects of alcohol and
criminal behavior for five years and the
truth of the matter is,
is that almost no men would be
aggressive ever if they weren't drunk.
So if,
if there,
if the front,
if the fraternities were alcohol free,
almost all of this would immediately
disappear.
Alcohol makes people,
well,
partly the reason that alcohol is fun is
because it's completely disinhibiting.
Yeah.
So,
yeah,
you're right.
I'm thinking of things like rape culture
would exist without stripping what is
actually making them.
Well,
what happens with alcohol?
I mean,
we did some studies looking at how
alcohol makes people aggressive because
it does,
it's one of the only drugs that actually
makes aggressive,
even cocaine doesn't make people
aggressive,
but alcohol does.
So for example,
one of the things my supervisor did was
he would bring people into the lab and
get them pretty intoxicated,
you know,
like up enough so that they would be at
the level that you would hit if you were
out for a party pre drinking,
let's say.
And then they would play a competitive
shark game,
or the,
one of the protagonists was a computer.
And so the drunk people,
so you could shock you're,
you're,
uh,
opponent if they violated some rule or
at any other time if you felt like it.
And the,
the drunk people would shock them harder
and longer.
And so one theory was,
well,
people who are drunk just don't know
what they're doing.
Okay.
So what my advisor did was he had people
write down the duration and level of the
sharks that they were administering and
when they were drunk,
that made them administer longer and
harder shocks.
So it isn't at all that people don't
know what they're doing.
What it is is they don't care what
they're doing.
That's a whole different thing.
They don't lose self consciousness.
What they lose is the,
the worry of the fear of the
consequences that's gone.
And plus for some people,
alcohol is also a psychomotor
stimulants.
So they get ramped up,
especially on the ascending limb of the
blocked blood alcohol curve.
And then the alcohol knocks out the fear
or inhibition of their behavior.
So it Lord knocks,
knocks out any effect of significance of
longterm consequences.
Did I thought someone had a question
there?
Okay.
By not caring,
you mean like on an ethical level
because they,
boy,
they must care if they want to
administer more shock.
Oh,
they don't care about the negative
consequences.
Care,
but flipping.
Oh,
sure.
That's,
that's,
you know,
well,
anger aggression is,
is a positive emotional state in park.
You know,
it's an approach behavior.
So it also activates approach and
withdrawal circuits.
But if it's successful anger,
there's a,
there's a huge kick in it and that can
be,
that can be boosted upwards by,
by alcohol.
So
you don't need alcohol to do that sort
of thing.
So I think that
right.
But that was a very,
that was a very,
there were,
there was a very specific condition and
some of that might also apply in places
like fraternities.
Right.
I think elocon innovation for sure.
But I think that also this whole society
of Internet form and normalizing kind of
violence against women has also,
like you don't have the societal
cultural inhibition has also been
hurricane to remove some of the,
absolutely.
Anyway,
yeah.
Well I would like to have,
I would like to continue this
discussion,
but let me continue to go through this.
So,
okay.
so what happens after they wake up is
that they sew fig leaves together and
make themselves aprons.
Now,
I don't know if you know this and you
probably don't,
but you know,
every single line of this story has bred
thousands and thousands of pages and
thousands and hours of,
of discussions about what it means.
And this line is no exception.
And basically what this story says here,
or at least one of the interpretations
of the story,
is that as soon as people wake up and
realize they're naked,
they make clothing and put it on.
And that's culture,
right?
That's so as soon as nakedness is on the
table,
then people put culture between
themselves and the vision of their
evaluators.
And so the,
the apron is the,
the representative of the fact that as
soon as animals wake up and realize
they're naked,
they use culture as a,
as a coping mechanism or it's not a
coping mechanism as a way of adapting to
that emergent situation.
And you know,
one of the things that people do pretty
much worldwide is where clothes now,
it's not a universal,
although it does seem to be a universal
in so far as clothes are always used,
at least for decorative purposes.
But in virtually every culture,
human beings are closed and we have been
for a very long period of time.
Now.
Partly that's because while we don't
have any body hair and so we get cold,
especially if we live in northern
climates or we need to protect herself
from the sun and so forth.
But that certainly by no means the only
reason,
even when we're as modern people were in
temperature can clue controlled
climates.
It's not like we're wandering around
without our clothes on.
So it's a,
it's a,
a form of boundary between ourselves and
the natural world and we immediately
adopted.
And the reason for that,
I mean the reason,
the motivational reasons that's laid out
in the stories because people know that
there know that they're naked,
the transformation produces immediate
enlightenment.
Adam and Eve can finally see there now
transcended vision produced by
incorporation of what was forbidden
produces within them.
Avascular heightened self consciousness,
a terrible catastrophe for limited
being,
but a preconditioned for genuine
individual existence.
Adam and eve instantly realize their
individual naked vulnerability,
a realization that emerges during
cognitive development at a very young
age.
And in fact that the only human being
seemed cognizant of in any complex
sense.
What does knowledge of naked
vulnerability mean?
It means that human beings are painfully
conscious of their limitations.
We know that we are flawed in
relationship to our ideals.
We understand that our being is limited
in place in time.
We know we are vulnerable to death,
disease and insanity.
We know that we can be betrayed by her
embodied being and undermine socially by
our peers and even by our friends,
by our friends,
and all of this makes us ashamed,
fearful.
Unselfconscious.
Now,
next question.
So when Adam and eve become,
they get there,
they eat this fruit and they figured out
that they're naked and then they put on
clothes on clothes on.
But one of the things that the snake
tells them is that as soon as they
become awake,
they're also going to know the
difference between good and evil.
Now,
I took that long.
It took me an awful long time to figure
out what that could possibly meet.
But one of the things that I was trying
to figure out as well,
the thing is,
as soon as you know that you're naked
and imagine that you can really
comprehend your limitations,
you don't really understand what they
are,
then that means that you understand your
vulnerability or at least to some degree
that you understand your vulnerability.
And the thing that's so interesting is
that the fact that I can understand my
own vulnerability means that I can be
empathic,
right?
Because I can also understand your
vulnerability and we can mirror that
back and forth.
So I would say,
well that's part of what enables us to
comprehend good.
But there's a terrible downside to that
too,
which is that as soon as I know that I'm
vulnerable and then I know exactly what
that means,
I know exactly how I can hurt you.
And that's a hurt that goes beyond what
animals do when they destroy one
another.
Like if a,
if a wolf is trying to take down a a
cow,
say it's a pretty hideous process.
You know,
like the wolves,
the wolves will take pieces of the cow.
Well,
it's standing up.
So it's not that they go in for the kill
and they do it as fast as they possibly
can.
I mean,
they do that,
but only because they don't want to get
kicked to death by the cow.
So it's pretty bloody awful.
And you know,
if you,
if you've ever read about Mya
chimpanzees hunting colobus monkeys for
example,
that's a pretty brutal situation.
Cause the chimps,
we'll catch the call us monkeys,
which weigh about 38 pounds and tear
them to pieces and eat them while
they're still alive.
So they're like screaming madly away.
It doesn't stop the chimps at all.
So it's not like predation in the wild
is brief and,
and,
and a merciful by any sort of natural
order,
but it's no more horrible than it
happens.
It has to be.
Whereas with people,
that's a whole different story,
you know?
So if,
I mean,
if you,
if people have been torturing each
other,
especially in warfare for a very,
very long period of time,
you know,
and there are certainly in tribal
warfare in particular,
I mean one of the things that the tribes
pride themselves on is the ability to
keep a captured soldier long alive for
the longest period of time possible.
Well torturing him in the most painful
way possible.
And so that can mean weeks and you can't
understand exactly how to take someone
else apart in every possible way that
you can take someone apart until you
understand how you could be taken apart.
And so I think that as soon as you do
recognize your own vulnerability,
you have transcended mere good and bad
and moved into the domain of good and
evil.
So cause you can treat someone else like
you would want to be treated.
But you can also,
there's no limits to your imagination
for cruelty.
I mean,
and there are truly no limits.
I mean
you see in situations like,
I don't know if you've ever read the
book the Rape of Nan King,
but that's a truly horrifying book.
The Rape Nan King.
And it's about what happened when Japan
occupied China during the Second World
War.
The estimates are that some three to
400,000
people were raped and brutalized and
tortured in Nan king.
And what seemed to happen was the
Japanese soldiers at that time were
products of the Prussian military school
because the Japanese and adopted that as
their model.
And they were basically taught that
everyone who wasn't Japanese was
subhuman.
And it's pretty easy to teach people
that because you can teach people that
those people who aren't them are
subhuman at the drop of a hat.
I mean it's,
it's a natural way for us to think.
And so when the Japanese went into Nan
king,
there was no limit on what they were
allowed to do to the Chinese.
And what basically happened was,
you can imagine this because people can
imitate.
What basically happened was you could
take the most psychopathic,
single Japanese soldier that you could
possibly imagine.
And then find a group those and then
find the one person who had the most
vivid imagination for may have an eval.
And then you could imagine him setting
the tone for the entire occupation.
And that's exactly what happened.
It was competitive brutality.
And so,
and you don't get at competitive
brutality until you understand exactly
what you're doing and you don't
understand what you're doing until you
know how people can be hurt.
And you don't understand that until you
know how you can be hurt.
And so that's also an emergent
consequence of self consciousness
now.
So you might think,
well,
is there any,
is there any support in this story for
such a hypothesis?
Well,
I think that thing that comes next
supports it.
So,
and this is another part of this story
that I think is by no means patriarchal.
I think it's exactly the opposite.
So one of the things that gender,
while I'll read you the,
or read the story.
So now they've,
they've found out they're naked and they
covered themselves up.
And so now God comes walking through the
garden and Adam and eve heard the voice
of the Lord God walking in the garden in
the cool of the day.
And Adam and his wife hid themselves
from the presence of the Lord God
amongst the trees of the garden.
So they hadn't been doing that before,
so it hadn't been hiding from God.
So now what we have is the idea that as
soon as people become vulnerable,
they hide from God.
And I believe that to be as close to
literally true as anything that you can
really utr.
And I'll talk about why that is in a
moment.
And the Lord God called Unto Adam and
said unto him,
where Art Thou?
And he said,
I heard dive voice in the garden.
And I was because I was naked.
So I hid myself.
And God said,
who told you that you were naked?
Have you eaten of the tree?
Whereof I commanded thee that thou
should not eat.
And the man said,
the woman whom thou gave us to be with,
she gave me of the tree and I did eat.
Okay.
So that's,
that's an amazing story.
So the first thing that happens is
there's an intimation that before the
emergence of self consciousness that
human beings walked with God in the
garden.
And so there was an unbroken line of
communication in some sense between the
creature and the divine totality.
It's the link was not broken.
Now one of the things that's
characteristic of the Shamana trends
tradition,
and this seems to be an idea that's
basically spread worldwide,
is that there was a time back in time
when the connection between heaven and
earth was unbroken.
And the idea that there's a fall and
that the fall involves a tree and a
snake is unbelievably well distributed.
It's ridiculously well distributed.
So now that might be because maybe that
was the story that we all knew before
the diaspora,
you know,
before the diaspora out of Africa.
And that people have just been retelling
it forever since,
since then,
so many hundreds of thousands of years
ago.
Or it might be that it's a story that's
so built into our architecture that,
you know,
when we,
when we come up across approximations of
it in,
in stories that people tell one another,
that it rings true somehow and we
collected recollected and retell it.
Nobody really knows.
But so what happens is that there's this
idea of unbroken communication between
Adam and eve before the development of
self consciousness.
But then self consciousness emerges and
they both realize they're naked and then
they covered themselves up.
But then the next thing that happens is
that they hide from God.
Now you didn't know.
It's pretty primitive.
It's really,
I think this part of the story is
actually a comedy because they're,
they're really acting in a very
brainless manor.
It's like,
first of all,
what are they going to do?
They're hiding from God behind trees.
That strikes me that that's a very
ineffective way of hiding from God since
he can probably see three trees and if
they thought about it for two tenths of
a second,
they'd figure that out.
Right?
So they might be conscious and self
conscious,
but they're,
they're not really very bright yet.
And then God calls Adam on it.
And the first thing Adam does is blame
the woman,
which isn't exactly the opposite of what
you just,
you would expect from a patriarchal
story as far as I'm concerned because he
comes across as a complete Dweeb,
you know,
I mean he,
he,
he wouldn't do,
you would think that if the writers of
this story would have wanted to,
wanted men to look particularly good,
that Adam would have stood up and
protected,
eat,
not ratted her out the first possible
moment.
So,
but I think,
I think that men do complain to God that
women make themselves conscious.
I think they do that all the time.
And I think that manifests itself in
resentment and,
and especially if they're not being
successful in,
in the,
in the game of attracting female
attention.
So they complained to God all the time
about the fact that women are making
them self conscious and that produces a
tremendous amount of resentment.
So anyways,
the man says,
the woman who,
the woman who you gave to me.
So he blames God too,
which I think is pretty funny.
She gave me of the tree and I did eat.
So now there's a deeper meaning here
too,
which is that the reason that human
beings no longer walk with God is
because they're embarrassed about their
own vulnerability.
And I also believe that to be the case
because you know,
when you think
it isn't only the worst of ourselves
that we hide from each other,
it's also the best of ourselves.
And I think,
in fact,
we're more likely to hide the best of
ourselves in the worst because like if I
manifest the worst of myself socially
and it gets rejected,
it's like,
well,
who the hell cares about that?
You know?
It's like that's my second rate attempt.
And it's not something I'm particularly
proud of anyways.
And if,
you know,
if you're not that happy about it,
well it's not the real me.
And so who cares?
But where are your most vulnerable is if
you try to do something that's as good
as you can do and you lay that out for
public evaluation.
And that's why neat you said for
example,
that if you really want to punish
someone,
you punish them for their virtues,
not for their faults.
And so people are afraid of letting
their virtues be seen because that
really reveals their vulnerability,
like that reveals the true extent of
their potential big.
And that's something that someone who
has the motivation could immediately
capitalize on and tortured them to death
for.
And I think like that's basically the
plot of every high school coming of age
movie that's ever been made so
well now they've done it.
So God says,
I read here,
let me read this because I thought this
was pretty funny.
Self conscious knowledge of
vulnerability makes the individual too
afraid to walk with God.
This is avoidance of meaning,
responsibility and destiny.
Such avoidance has catastrophic
consequences.
Existence properly undertaken produces a
condition of being that makes knowledge
of find a tude tolerable that properly
undertaking undertaken existence means
the embodiment of logos in spite of
vulnerability to hide from God as a
consequence of revealed nakedness is to
destroy the incarnation of logos and to
immediately become subject to the
privations of merely human existence.
Adam's sin,
which is partly his curiosity,
inspired rebellion is also more than
that.
And what is more may also be more
significant.
Adam refuses to continue his
relationship with logos because he is
awake and afraid and he believed he
blames the architect,
architect of femininity eve for his
enlightened cowardice.
After all,
she made him self conscious.
His immediate abandonment of courage and
responsibility endears him neither to
God nor to woman.
Perhaps this is the real sin of Adam.
Had he not compromised himself further
after eating the apple,
God might have relented and allowed them
to stay in paradise and that's not a
reading of of genesis that I've ever
really come across because the sin has
always presented as the original eating.
But you know,
he acts pretty damn reprehensive Lee.
In fact as badly as you possibly could
under circumstances like that.
So,
and it's certainly the case that women,
men acting towards women in that manner,
blaming them for their own self
conscious vulnerability is is definitely
a major source of avoidable strife
throughout the world and has been for,
you know,
all of the centuries that we've been in
self conscious association with women
about the letter of the law.
Yeah,
well I think,
I think that's right.
So,
okay,
so what happens?
Well,
what happens is what you'd expect.
God just lays out the the consequences
of this.
And he says,
okay,
unto the woman,
he said,
I will greatly multiply thy sorrow and
die conception in sorrow shalt thou
bring forth children and I desire shall
be to die husband and he shall rule over
thee.
Now it's often read is that's often read
as again as a patriarchal statement that
God punishes women by dooming them to be
ruled by men.
But I don't think that that's what it
says it all.
What it says basically as,
okay,
well a sequence of events has just
occurred.
The sequence of events is that event
which,
which caused the emergence of self
consciousness.
Now we can assume that that was
associated with cortical expansion.
So one of the things we know that
happened during cortical expansion is
that the baby's head became sedan big,
that it could hardly get out during
childbirth.
So there's been a bunch of physiological
consequences of that.
One is women's hips are wider than men.
If they were any wider women couldn't
run.
So women hit the limits of hip
expansion.
And so the hip expansion helped,
made the pelvic pelvic gap through which
the baby is born sufficiently large.
So they had could get through but barely
like seriously,
barely.
And that's why there's partly why there
are so many [inaudible] in sections.
But one of the other consequences of
that,
there were a couple of them.
One is babies are born way younger than
they should be.
So for a mammal of our size,
women should have a gestation period of
two years,
not nine months.
So babies are born fetal.
And the second is that the baby's head,
the bones in the head aren't,
are grown together.
And so one of the things that happens
during birth is the baby's head
compresses and it compresses a lot.
Like when a baby comes out,
it actually can be its head,
can normal speak cone shaped because of
the tremendous that's crushing the head
during the birth process.
And so birth is very,
very painful for human beings and it's
very,
very dangerous.
And you know,
part of the human story is that the hero
is always threatened at birth.
And the reason for that,
the reason that that's true among human
beings is because human babies are
unbelievably vulnerable.
You know,
and even at birth they're highly likely
to die.
Child mortality has been a terrible
burden on humanity while really up until
the last century,
you know,
and child mortality rates have been
plummeting like mad in developed
countries over the last 10 years.
But you know,
prior to the 20th century,
children die didn't,
but the majority of children died.
Women died in childbirth all the time.
So the idea that women were going to
have sorrow in childbirth and in
conception doesn't seem to me to be
precisely a divine doctrine.
It's just an observation of exactly what
was going to happen.
So,
and then,
you know,
once the baby's born,
the same damn problem emerges because
the baby so premature and so helpless
that the woman is basically doomed to be
nonself sufficient for a reasonably
extensive period of time.
And so we could say,
well that's at least until the baby is,
I would say five absolutely minimum.
You know,
even chimps carry their babies around
for about three years with one hand,
you know,
so they're,
the females are down to one arm.
And so human mothers are at a tremendous
disadvantage in the immediate aftermath
of birth.
And part of the consequence of that is
that they're doomed to be reliant on
men.
What the hell else could possibly
happen?
I mean,
the women put themselves together in
groups and try to support each other
during pregnancy and childbirth.
And that happens in multiview most human
societies.
But it still boils down to the fact that
in order to redress the balance,
the woman ends up dependent on a man.
And one of the consequences of that is
that,
you know,
he's got more power than she does.
And so it's a,
it's a statement of destiny rather than
a sentence of,
of revenge.
And Unto Adam,
he said,
because you have hearkened unto the
voice of your wife and have eaten of the
tree,
which I commanded thee,
saying thou shall not eat of it cursed
it is the ground for the ice sake in
sorrow,
shelldale eat of it all die days of the
life of the life of thy life.
Thorns also and thistles shall it bring
forth to thee and thou shall eat the
herb of the field in the sweat of the
face.
THY face shalt thou eat bread till thou
return unto the ground for out of it,
West thou taken for Dusko Art and unto
dust,
thou shall return pretty damn dismal.
I mean,
the women get knocked really hard to
begin with,
but it's not like the men get away Scot
free.
Basically that the statement of the
consequence of the emergence of self
consciousness is that men are doomed to
toil their entire life and then to die.
And I also think that that's not
something that characterizes any other
animal because human beings work.
And the reason we work is because we're
conscious of the future and we're
conscious of all the potential
catastrophes the future can bring,
including the catastrophes for our
family.
And so the consequence of that is that
instead of being directly immersed in
the pleasures of the moment,
people always have to forego those
pleasures to,
to stave off the potential array of
future catastrophes that were firmly
aware of because we're self conscious.
And so that's when history starts,
you know,
and the fundamentalist say,
well the world began when God created
the world after seven days.
You know?
And the funny thing is is that there's
an element of that that's true.
History does not begin until human
beings become self conscious before that
it's mere unconscious animal existence.
And so to some degree,
the emergence of self consciousness is
the beginning of the being that we would
consider specifically human being.
So,
and exactly what that means on a cosmic
level is no,
no one can be certain of that because we
don't understand the relationship
between consciousness.
And being so on one the one end you can
think of us as occupying some little
speck of dust at the corner of some
irrelevant galaxy and an infinite
universe.
But by the same token,
we're also,
this is the only place that we know of
where consciousness exists.
And if consciousness is,
if,
if being is dependent on consciousness,
and I think that you can make a very
strong case that it is,
then there's no reason to assume that
this isn't the center of things despite
the,
you know,
despite our reinterpretation of that
over the last 300 years.
So the god,
therefore the Lord God sent him forth
from the garden of Eden to till the
ground from whence he was taken.
So we drove out the man and placed at
the east of the garden of Eden Cherubims
and a flaming sword,
which turned every way to keep the way
of the tree of life.
So there's no going back.
You know,
it's funny because one of the classic
Shamonic mythologies is the attempt to
go back to get the tree of life,
to get the fruit of the tree of life.
And you can see that in Gilgamesh,
for example,
which is a story that's either an older
than the Enuma elish.
So Gilgamesh goes to the bottom of the
ocean.
So he goes to the bottom of being itself
in one of his heroic ventures to grab
the herb of immortality,
but he loses it on the way up.
And there's an idea in the shamanic
traditions that when the [inaudible] are
going up and down the tree of life,
that one of the things they're trying to
do is to go into this heavenly realm to
bring back that which will confer
immortality upon people.
But there's no,
no one has been successful at doing
that.
And that's a very,
very widespread story.
And there's also something to it.
Something I don't understand,
but there's something about it that's
accurate.
Right,
right,
right.
Yeah.
Well,
the fact that the story,
the story suggests that there's is a way
of obtaining it,
mortality that people have been able to
voyage to but not to bring back.
So,
and that's a failed hero story happens
all the time.
It's like the person who goes to fight
with the dragon to get the goal but
can't bring the gold back or ends up
inside the dragons belly.
It's a failed hero story.
And Gilgamesh,
for example,
is a failed hero's story.
Now the story is,
one of the things that happens in
Christianity is that there's a twist in
the failed hero story because Christ
dies and then comes back.
And so there's this,
there's this idea in Christianity that
voluntary death solves the problem of
death.
So yeah,
I don't think that's an or question.
I think it's an end question.
I actually think that it requires both,
but I don't exactly know what that
means.
Okay.
So like there's,
there's,
there's an,
there was a very old idea that the way
to overcome death is to accept it,
but it isn't exactly clear what except
means.
Obviously it means to accept it on a
metaphysical level,
which is to say,
to not deny the validity of being merely
because your finite.
But I don't think that's all it means
because I think most of these stories
have a reality that plays itself out at
the level of the material reality that
we're familiar with and day to day
existence.
And if the metaphysical plane at the
same time at that somehow those are the
same thing.
There's in some way that we don't
understand.
So I've had strong intimations that
death is partly a repair mechanism.
So
I mean one of the things that seems to
happen when you go to sleep at night,
that that's,
that's,
that's something that that brings you
close to death.
Your consciousness certainly disappears
and the deeper you go into sleep,
it's only in the deepest,
deepest stages of sleep that your body
produces human growth hormone and does
the repairs that are necessary.
So you have to be,
you have to become extraordinarily
relaxed and let go of everything in
order to enter a physiological condition
where you can be optimally restructured.
And I don't know how deep you can go
into that.
There seems to be a diametric opposition
analysis,
mystical realm.
So perhaps definitely one that needs to
emerge.
Well,
it served.
That certainly does happen when you go
to sleep.
I mean,
you leave the realm of normal day to
day,
individual wakefulness and you descend
into a realm of fantasy and,
and immobility.
And so there's,
there's a,
there's a sick click interconnection
between those two states of being,
you know,
and it's certainly the case that when
people become unhealthy that their sleep
wake cycles become tremendously
disrupted.
They don't sleep properly anymore and
then they really start to age and
disintegrate.
So,
all right,
so that's that.
Now I want to tell you this,
Cain and Abel Story.
So,
and then,
Yup.
What do you mean?
Well,
you know,
when I placed these talks on the
Internet,
people will criticize them and say that
I'm stretching,
you know,
that I'm attempting to,
to use scientific evidence to justify
the reality of these stories.
So I don't mean,
I don't think that is what I'm trying to
do.
I think what I'm trying to do is to
figure out what the hell these stories
mean.
I think the reason that the,
that the,
the,
um,
isomorphism is there is because these
stories are true.
I just don't think we know what that
means.
So would you expect this,
particularly this one or maybe if we
look closer at,
well,
I can tell you that the story,
I'm going to try to get to it.
We missed a lecture unfortunately.
But what are the stories I wanted to
tell you is the story of Buddha.
The Buddhist story is exactly the same
story as the story in genesis plus the
story of the reincarnation of,
or the resurrection of Christ.
It's the same story.
And Buddha obtains enlightenment under a
tree.
You know,
Christ attains enlightenment on a tree,
but you know,
the tree that Christ attains a
resurrection on is the tree of life.
And it's the tree that grows out of the
place where Adam died.
So that's part of the,
this,
the story that this association
associated with Christian symbolism.
If you look at Greek Orthodox,
Russian Orthodox,
crucifixions,
the crucifix is always got Adam Skull at
the bottom.
So Adam dies.
And what Christ represents is the thing
that transcends that death and that,
and this is very important.
I mean one of the ideas that's nested
there,
and I think this is the prime idea,
is that you can overcome death if you
can accept it voluntarily,
if you can embrace it,
if you can see it as a necessary part of
being,
if you can detach from it your
presupposition that it's only evil and
destructive.
And so now that's a hypothesis,
right?
It's a hypothesis.
But
you know,
because one of the things you got to ask
yourself,
for example,
you can say that existence is
meaninglessness,
meaningless.
You know that,
that we're in a clockwork world in the
Newtonian world,
which we're clearly not.
But you could except the Newtonian
worldview that we're in a mechanical
universe and that things unfolded and
mechanical and deterministic way that
consciousness has empathy.
Phenomenal.
And then when you're done,
you're done.
And that's it.
And this is all a consequence of random,
of randomness laying itself out across
time,
randomness and causality.
That's one way of looking at it.
And there's powerful reasons for looking
at it that way.
But there are,
there are consequences to looking at it
that way.
First of all,
we do not know that that's true and we
certainly know that the world is not
deterministic.
And we certainly understand that there
were plenty of processes at play that
are not random.
Sexual selection is not random.
So,
and sexual selection,
it's the reason we're,
the way they we are is because of sexual
selection.
So we've made conscious decisions the
entire way about,
you know,
what elements of human forms should
propagate themselves into the future.
Now,
Nino,
nobody seems to take the metaphysical
implications of that seriously.
And basically what happened,
Darwin was,
uh,
was extremely impressed by the power of
sexual selection,
but because people couldn't handle the
notion that evolution was shaped,
say,
in large part by female choice,
the biologist ignored sexual selection
for 100 years after Darwin published,
uh,
hip published his great work on
evolution.
It's only recently that people have been
able to take the sort of thing seriously
at all.
And we also don't understand epigenetics
You know,
over the epigenetics.
It's obvious that our own experiences
can modify our genetic structure.
And the other thing that we don't
understand,
there's,
there's some animations and I'll send
you guys the link to this,
but I saw some amazing animations in the
recent,
in the last couple of weeks showing how
DNA,
um,
separates and then reassembles during
cell division.
And so they've,
they've modeled this at the molecular
level using x Ray crystallography.
And so you could,
it's unbelievable what's going on down
at the ad level.
Basically what you see is there's these
little machines that are made out of
molecules,
like single molecules that have arms and
legs that walk around and move things
and put things together.
Like you look at it down there,
you think that's computational.
Those bloody things are,
I think their quantum super computers
operating at that level.
Cause those goddamn things are smart.
You know,
like there are these little machines,
they pull dna apart,
then they loop it around and cut it and
they send the loops often at the same
time as the DNA separates and it has to
be remade.
These things are grabbing molecules as
they come by,
like literally mechanically and sticking
them on the DNA chain and it's,
it's,
it's so computational that it's,
it's mind boggling.
I'll send you the links.
It's like I looked at that.
It just,
it just blew me away.
You know?
And we have no idea what kind of
computational processes are available at
the micro scale that we do know that
quantum computation as possible.
And you know,
that means that computation can be
occurring in,
at,
in it with extreme power,
at levels of resolution.
We would have never imagined possible.
But I can tell you look at those bloody
videos and you look at them with a fresh
mind.
The idea that what's happening down at
the molecular level is it the idea that
it's not intelligent is insane.
I mean those bloody things or making
decisions,
it's not deterministic.
It's way too complicated to be
deterministic.
Looks more like a car factory or
something like that.
It's incredible molecules,
single molecules like sometimes a five
or six Adams.
So there's like the one things that when
they're making the telomeres that pull
the DNA apart,
they like whip out these telomeres which
are made out of four molecules.
They kind of make a square that extends,
there's little gadgets that are putting
those together and then when they've got
them all done and they need to signal
the fact that they were finished,
these other little molecules that look
like little stick man,
they grab a molecule and they walked
down the telomeres like one foot after
another carrying this thing that's going
to be the message.
It's it's,
I wish I could show it to you.
It's unbelievable.
It's like just make your jaw drop and
it's intelligent.
There's no way that that's bierly
deterministic nor a chance.
Plus those bloody things can fix
mistakes in DNA.
So because your cells are repairing
mistakes in Dna all the time,
it's like,
well how do they do that?
Well,
if you,
if you bought a limit,
looks like they look at it and look at
it,
whatever the hell that means,
they're evaluating it to see where
there's a mistake.
So it's like,
oh,
it's,
it's like their little robots that are
doing diagnostics.
Diagnostics.
Yeah.
So it's,
it's all right.
So now,
okay,
so what happens after Adam and eve?
So,
Yup.
Yeah,
let's have a short break.
Okay.
Only let's do it for five minutes
because I really want to finish this
part before we end.
So while you're gone,
I'll show you this.
I'll find this animation.
You guys can come up here and take a
look at it cause it's mind boggling.